I want to deliver messages the Trump
personally doesn't want to hear there is
that picture that has now become famous
at the g7 summit the Atlantic wrote that
it's become kind of a laurel and yanny
moment with people having two different
views of it what have you learned about
what actually happened in that moment I
think the background is important it was
at this point it was towards the end of
the summit the Chancellor Merkel of
Germany and Prime Minister Trudeau of
Canada got together with some of the
allies and really wanted to press Trump
directly to sign the communique the one
that talked about a commitment to a
rules-based international order the
advisors had been working on until three
o'clock that morning straight through
the night including Kudlow from the
United States and Trump was sitting
there with his arms crossed clearly not
liking the fact that he felt like they
were ganging up on him
he eventually agreed he said okay he'll
sign it and at that point he stood up he
put his hand in his pocket his suit
jacket pocket and he took two starbursts
candies out threw them on the table and
said to Merkel here Angola don't say I
never give you anything and I would say
that that was a that really showed if
you won't if you want to look into what
was behind both the the the body
language there and also why it was that
after the meeting Trump was so agitated
and decided to tweet off against the
Canadian Prime Minister and decide to
pull his name out of the communique
completely unknown to Kudlow and others
that had been advising him I think
that's that's really the reason that's
his emotional state of that point so
President Trump had a starburst outburst
look I mean his personal relationship
with Merkel is deeply broken the leaders
obviously do not respect each other they
don't think that the other respects them
and it's pretty clear that they don't
and Trump's interest in multilateral
institutions that for him it feels like
a constraint not an opportunity but
looking at it from his point of view
could he possibly have been teasing and
meant for that to be a friendly gesture
is there any way that you could read
that
is there any way you could read that
into it you know it's hard to keeping in
mind the Trump didn't want to go to the
g7 he was convinced by his advisors the
day before that he needed to and one
thing we know about Trump is when he's
told to do things that he doesn't want
to do he doesn't respond to them easily
he showed up late he left early
he took his translation piece out of his
ear when the French president was
actually giving a speech he showed an
extraordinary lack of interest in
working with the allies all the way
through and again the private
conversations I've had with many of
these leaders over the course of the g7
summit really does Express